رام الله ينضم الينا الان مراسلنا ماجد
سعيد ماجد اهلا بك اولا ماذا عن الوضع في
جنين والضفه الغربيه بشكل عام
هي متوتره مدينه جنين
وتحديدا بالقرب من منها في قريه او بلده
كفردان همم قتل فلسطينيه برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيليه عندما اقتحم هذا الجيش البلده
منتصف همم بعد منتصف الليل الماضيه وقام
بمحاصرت منزلين لفلسطينيين قتل وكان نفس
عمليا من حاجز الجلفه القريب من مدينه
جنين قتلته همم ضابط اسرائيلي في منتصف في
ايلول من العام الماضي همم قام الجيش في
عمليه تفجير المنزلين منزلي هؤلاء همم
هذين شابين اللذين نفذ تلك العمليه
واثناء وتواجده في تلك البلباء كان هناك
اشتباكات ومواجهات مع مع شبان وعشرات شبان
الفلسطينين ادى ذلك الى مقتل فلسطينيين
احدهما من البلده والاخر من بلده اليامون
قريبا من مدينه جنين ايضا واصابه ثمانيه
فلسطينيين اخرين بينهم همم اصابه خطيره
كما تقول المصادر الطبيه الجيش الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا بهذه الاثناء هناك في
بلده برقين في جنين اشتباكات مع مسلحين في
الصيدليين في تلك البلده عندما اقتحمها
ويقوم بعمليه محاوله اعتقال عمليات
الاعتقال في المجمل العام لهذه لان كانت
ايضا في مختلفه الغربيه من شمالها الى
جنبها كان هناك 15 في فلسطين ينجرح
اعتقالهم في هجمات واا عمليات للجيش
الاسرائيلي في مختلف الغربيه في سلفيت
طولكرم في نابلس في جنين في بيت لحم وايضا
في منطقه الخليل الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا في
منطقه همم
ريحه تحديدا في منطقه الجسمي كنا همم قد
احتجز سته اطفال فلسطينيين منذ ساعات
النهار الاولى اللي عده ساعات
وكان يطالب باولياء امورهم كي يخرج عنهم
هذه العمليات الاسرائيليه تاتي في اطار ما
يقوم بها الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ نحو سنه من
الان
لو سمحت وزير الامن القومي
هذا الاسبوع هذا الاقتحام ليس الاول لبن
كثير ولكنه الاول وهو يتقلد منصب وزير في
حكومه ياهو هذا الاقتحام حضرت منه حركه
حماس وايضا في هذا الصبيان انه سيجر مزيد
من التوتر في الارض الفلسطينيين مجد سعيد
مراسلنا من رام الله اشكرك على كل هذه
المعلومات